Since 1999, Gallup has asked employed
adults about satisfaction with their
boss or immediate supervisor. The first
time they asked this question, 82% said
that they were completely or very
satisfied. In 2019, a similar 84% gave
this response. On the 20 occasions they
have asked this question, no more than 7%
have ever told Gallup they were
completely dissatisfied. Does the boss's
sex matter? Since 1953, Gallup has asked
people whether they would rather work
for a man or a woman. At the time,
two-thirds said that they would prefer a
male boss, five percent of female, and a
quarter said it would make no difference.
In 2017, 23 percent said that they would
prefer a man, 21 percent a woman, but 55
percent said it would make no difference.
Finally, could you be the boss? Do you
know more, or could you do a better job
than he or she could? In a poll from 2017,
38 percent said yes, but 56 percent said
that they didn't feel that way.
Do you like your boss? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.